he'd just come back to it we're talking
about a whole different topic he's like
Big O Tires really you could just own 12
Big O Tires and that's it and he was
just going back to a new example of one
of these like shitty brick and mortar
chains that are like you know so easy
sweaty cash flow business
[Music]
all right we're gonna start the Pod but
before we do we have an announcement we
are looking to hire a new producer this
producer is going to be the person who
sits live on these podcasts helps us
edit them and make the videos and uh
podcast popular helps us get guests so
we're hiring we're hiring I I almost
call them a band manager it's like you
know the band manager's job is to make
sure that the band
blows up right and so this podcast has
grown a lot it's time that we find
somebody who wants to take it to the
next level booking amazing guests uh
helping us brainstorm great content
segments and be like guys people love it
when you do the Blue Collar side hustles
let's make sure we hit those every week
and uh you know keep us on our A-game
um make the audio the video tighter make
the YouTube channel better make it pop
uh we want somebody who's great at this
uh ideally we hire somebody who's
already a fan of the show and is looking
to basically hang out with us a few
times a week see how we operate loves
making great content loves getting
content made and has the I don't know
like kind of like the taste and the
skills to put out a great content
product and that's what we're looking
for so if that's you uh you can reach
out you can email me uh it's Sean
seanpuri.com so s-h-a-a-n at
s-h-a-n-p-u-r-i.com and I'll forward it
to our team uh over at HubSpot that is
uh that is vetting and interviewing
everybody so we're gonna hire somebody
this next few weeks
and it's a full-time position if you're
an amateur you've never done this before
you maybe you'll get noticed but you
have to be really good we're not looking
for people who are trying to take huge
risks on we're trying to find people who
are the best uh we've already had
hundreds of people apply so we really
want the best people out there if you've
never done this before you could still
throw your throw your your resume out
there and try to impress us but make
sure you do that
um if you've already been there done
that that that's awesome too
so check it out email Sean Sean at
seanpurry.com all right let's get to the
Pod
all right
you ready
for the greatest show I've ever done
a lot of people have uh we got a lot of
good comments on the last show people
were saying someone asked me an
interesting question they go your guys's
Cadence is really good you guys uh you
talk really fast and it feels quickly
and then someone said do you do
something
to one another because Sean and I are
remote do you do something to one
another to let each other know that it's
your turn to speak and I was thinking
I think we just have we just know each
other well enough that we know how to do
it but there is something that we each
do at least I pay really attention to
you when you do it and I try to give you
the signal which is you open up your
mouth when you want to say something and
then you let it sit open for a minute do
you know what I mean the zoom hack
because you're like
you're like uh and the little uh is
without the without the sound is
basically just satellite now but you
know because on the recording you're not
gonna see it so it's a silent signal
whereas if you're doing that in person
it'd be a little like strange
um but yeah it definitely works the hard
one is during interviews because during
interviews the guest is talking we don't
know when they're gonna stop they're
opening up like probably a bunch of like
paths you could go down like oh they've
mentioned three things they said it was
really hard then they said they met a
guy who who was the guy and they said
that it really changed the perspective
but how what did it change and so you're
like and then we don't know who's gonna
go we're both pretty insatiably curious
I have a bad habit of just like talking
too much in general in life and so then
it's like we don't know which path we're
gonna go and we don't know who's gonna
decide
um so A Team interview I think is really
hard uh it's it's very that's very hard
the interviews are easier in person but
what we do is this now with just us I
think it's way easier on Zoom because
I've gotten so used to it also I've
recorded in studios like you have done
lately you're gonna talk about your trip
in La I cannot stand when there's a
third party there because I'm constantly
trying to entertain her or him like the
like the person there but uh yeah we it
what people don't see is we do a good
job of opening our mouths just a little
bit so the other person knows when it's
done
Pro tips for everybody yeah that's what
you learn after three years of uh
intense podcasting one of the top ranked
business podcasts in the world that you
don't get these kind of insights
anywhere else no oh my God someone was
like you guys are so fast-paced I'm like
yeah it wears me out I usually always
take like a 20 or 30 minute nap I just
close my eyes and lay down on this couch
that guy's definitely just listening to
us on 2X and is like wow these guys are
strange you know he doesn't know he hit
the button on his app uh so you just
went to LA last episode I asked you
about it you just said I'm gonna do a
whole thing where I tell you about it I
love these things because you're very
observant you uh you you are you have
great observations and you don't ever
leave your house so when you do you're
extra you're you have great observations
Boy Meets World and uh the thing about
you is you've got like a child's like
awe of the world because like you're so
sheltered and you live in such a bubble
and so you say these things that I'm
used to but I love just hearing it
anyway I stand far backhanded compliment
one of the finest uh yes all those
things are true there used to be a
website back in the day I don't know if
you remember I don't know if it's still
up probably is uh little big details did
you ever see this website no and it's a
great little blog it's a Tumblr blog
actually that's like tumblr's not even
around anymore but what they did was
supposed to 2017. they were just it's
like a swipe file so they would just
capture any example of like
a small thing that a company did well so
um like on a Google doc on a Google doc
when you go to share it and you don't
name it it just takes the first line of
what you spoke about and it makes that
the title of the Google Doc as opposed
to just naming it Untitled document yeah
exactly or like it says on Google if you
Google the word kerning every word that
shows up in the results has a large
amount of kerning right like the the
font
um or it'll be like you know the error
like the 404 page of this site instead
of just saying error has this really fun
um [__] poem or whatever it is and so
uh I love this website I love the name
little big details
um I love this site because it just gave
me a bunch of inspiration when back in
the day when I was like more of like a
PM product designer type guy
um but third
little big details are the secret of
life right I've said this before it's
the moments in between the moments like
it's not the big moments that matter
it's the moments in between those
moments that matter this is the product
version of that it's like here's the
little things I remember the first time
I used slack and our designer type the
hex code they were like oh yeah it's
gonna be color you know number eight
eight three three four four F
and then it just it automatically
swapped that to this color swatch so we
can see it area added the color swatch
to it in line right and we were just
like what the like it was a mic drop
moment in our in our every like our
design team was like okay I [__] with
this product like they like somewhere in
this a designer was like you know it
would be cool it'd be cool if you could
actually see the preview of the thing
because nobody knows what these numbers
mean and like I don't even know how they
did it with the Emoji size thing and it
was just like a little big detail and
there was a bunch of those with the
great with great products like slack
um that that kind of like we were in the
first hundred users of slack or
something and so it was very clear that
like this thing might become a thing
because the care that they took to this
so anyways the things I want to talk
about the LA trip they're not the big
moments it's not oh I met with this
famous person and here's the
groundbreaking Insight I tried to find a
bunch of the little big details a bunch
of the moments in between the moments I
think were interesting in their own way
this is for two reasons one I don't
really want to brag or I can't really
talk too much about the people I met and
what they said because it'd be kind of
airing out you know those private
meetings but two I think there's just a
lot of interesting stuff in these or at
least I think there could be so I wrote
down a bunch of very vague but slightly
intriguing bullet points and you could
pick but I will say here's the structure
so I go to LA
with Ben business partner Ben
um we do three things so we uh here's
the daily schedule morning is basically
meetings and a workout that was the goal
um midday was typically recording a
podcast live in person with someone that
we admired respected or thought was
really cool and then the evening was
always a dinner with kind of like
founder friends who were almost always
people who had sold their companies hold
one or more companies uh in the past and
we did that for five days straight so we
would leave the house at 8 A.M we would
get back around midnight and crash and
then do it all again the next day oh my
God and uh for me who's someone who's
almost always at home on I have two
little kids that are under the age of
you know four years old so uh you know
I'm on a kid's schedule typically this
was crazy but um it was it wasn't
awesome was an awesome experience so now
take it away all right so you have a
list of maybe 20 things I bolded about
half of them that intrigued me I want to
learn about
big company CEOs talking about laundry
mats
all right so this is the story we're out
at um one of the kind of like after
dinner just like let's go hang out this
other place so we're hanging at this
other place and it's me it's business
partner Ben and it's our buddy sulie and
we're hanging out
and um
Ben goes hey that's so and so
and be looking for us I'm like I don't
even I don't recognize the name or the
face so I'm like what are you talking
about he's like we did a call with him
two years ago
and I was like what he's like yeah we
did a zoom call for like 20 minutes with
that guy he introduced us to this guy
other guy and I was like
don't I mean I can't for the life of me
remember this guy and this guy by the
way doesn't remember us either right
like he doesn't recognize us either Ben
uh he's got like freaking the like you
know China has the facial recognition
software that this running at all times
using AI yeah Ben has that uh this
happens like five or six times during
the trip you would see someone walking
by and be like that's that girl from
Twitter
uh and so he does it he's like hey blah
blah blah and they're like surprised
he's like hey it's Ben we talked two
years ago on a zoom call for 20 minutes
and he's like I think you see the guy
kind of like doesn't really know what's
going on they're having dinner so we
merged dinners wait did you really yeah
we just merged Hangouts their crew was
awesome so they're they're best friends
from business school they went to
Harvard Business School together one of
them runs one of them is now CEO of a
public company can't say which one but
he's uh such a funny guy so uh assuming
multi-billion multi-billion dollar
company yeah over one billion dollars so
um we're hanging out and this guy who's
the CEO of a multi of a multi-billion
dollar company at the moment he goes um
he's like yeah he was like oh you do a
podcast what's a podcast what is it
called oh yeah I'll check it out right
is he kind of like he's like one of
those people that's like busy actually
doing something so he's like well it's
kind of detached from like the world of
like Twitter and podcasts and like
content creators and all the stuff but
as we're talking he's like oh you know
one thing I did see
what's with all these like entrepreneurs
who own laundromats and hvacs and [__]
yeah they're just buying laundromats
they're just making like a million
dollars a year owning a laundromat like
what is this they can't be true he's
like this is like he's like this
either this is not true and they're
lying or this is true what the hell are
we all doing why don't we all only like
15 laundromats he's like it could only
be one of two situations and so we had
this hilarious conversation with this
guy but there's not a third situation of
it is true and it's kind of stupid no he
was like if it's true that these things
are as you know sort of simple and cash
flowy as Pop as they sound
why would we all not just on 15 of these
and call it a day and he's like and if
it's not true why the hell are they
talking about it like it is and um I
just thought it was so funny because it
was like smart person it's kind of like
when you if you took a really healthy
person
to like a grocery store and walk through
the snack aisle they'd be like so this
is all just sugar
they'd be like well yeah there's like so
all the kids food is sugar and then all
the adult food is like sugar and salt
like what
you eat this why wouldn't you just eat
normal food and you're like I mean I
can't defend it it's just the way I
don't know it's just what it is that's
how he was talking about like
entrepreneurial content that he's run
into on on social media just like in
passing while he's like trying to like
go see friends photos he's like why is
this entrepreneur telling me that they
make so much money so easily doing
something so so stupid and hands-off
he's like it's either not hands off it
doesn't make that much money or we are
all idiots and because it is hands off
and makes that much money and I just
thought it was such a like it was so
funny the way he was ranting about it
and he was just like kept and then every
15 minutes during the conversation he'd
be like
he'd just come back to it we're talking
about a whole different topic he's like
Big O Tires really you could just own 12
Big O Tires and that's it and you just
come back to a new example of one of
these like shitty brick and mortar
chains that are like you know so easy
sweaty cash flow business I went through
this period so I was public about this I
bought property uh to do an Airbnb
because I was like you know let's see if
I'm interested in that and what I've
learned is exactly what that guy feels
which is
if you can make money on the internet or
like through content or software or
something like that the business is so
much better you can create a huge amount
of money from nothing right you need
nothing except you got to work on it
with real estate and laundromats and
[__] you make we're talking like single
digits if you're really lucky tens of
thousands of dollars a month in profit
and it's a pain in the butt man it is so
hard and you have to have a ton of money
to do it uh like it it's quite
challenging so I understand now I'm like
oh my God like I I have the skill set
this is so stupid to do this other thing
when this other when this internet thing
is so much easier
I feel I I totally understand what he's
saying and so the other great story this
guy told
um so I'm gonna try to do this without
giving away too much info so he um
you know he takes over SC of this
company he wasn't the original CEO he
becomes he gets hired SEO or become CEO
um
and now this company has like it's like
has big scale but it's not profitable so
the stock was getting kind of hammered
and the company wasn't doing so well
because it's not profitable
and um so there's all these theories so
if you if you just listen to like the
pundits they would be like it's a
category problem like this category
can't be profitable because of a b c and
d they're sort of like it's a more like
they're all theorizing about it and
they've made it sound like it's just a
law of physics that it's just not going
to work bad category like uh like like
like grocery delivery yeah like 15
minute grocery delivery or whatever
right yeah yeah and so that was if you
just listen to the smart pundits you
would have just been like well
impossible
um
and if you listen to the original team
they'd be like
um you know like yeah it's we're working
on it it's like no you're not dude every
single customer we lose we lose money
every time someone buys from us don't
you recognize how big of an issue this
is like how did you let this go on for
this long this way and he's like okay so
First Act is as CEO he goes to
um like the kind of like let's say the
place where the the kind of the product
is is is developed or made
um like it has like a real world product
it's like a it's a it's a business
that's like Tech enabled but it has like
a real world world component yeah
um similar to like an Uber or a um uh
like Airbnb has like you know there is
the physical place
so the guy goes and he's like we're like
so what'd you do and he's like I just
sat there
I just sat I got a chair and I sat down
in the middle and I just watched for
eight hours straight
he's like I just looked I just looked at
what was going on I had no preconceived
judgments I said let me just watch
what's actually happening here how is it
that we are losing so much money for
every order that we get every customer
that we get we lose money how is this
possible
um
and he just sits there and he watches it
watches and he's like oh
okay I see
we got too many people doing two little
[__] and the manager is not doing what
they're supposed to be doing and so he's
like I like that guy you're outside for
half the time and therefore this person
is not doing what they're doing and
these three people are all trying to do
the same thing he's like I didn't have
to like like it wasn't a theoretical
problem and it wasn't an inevitable
problem it was just a everybody's too
distanced from the thing problem
everybody nobody just sat here for eight
hours straight and just watched what the
hell is actually going on and they told
the story how they actually turned it
around now it's profitable and like so
on and so forth and so um I think that's
all I can say without giving too much
away but I just love this guy I love the
story the two things that he that he
said out loud was the like hey wait wait
pause time out time out we can all just
on Big O Tires and and call it a day
like if it's that easy we should be
doing if it's not that easy screw those
people for saying it and secondly his
like I'm just gonna go sit for eight
hours and watch and just really get to a
first like a like a a
clear understanding of what is actually
happening before we come to any other
conclusions
will you ever do one of these things so
I I dip my toes in it and my thing like
it's on paper it's successful it's just
like
ah it's just uh it's an emotional
baggage what do you think about yours or
are you ever going to do anything like
that you mean a business that has real
world sweatiness
yeah yeah
um yeah like for our econ thing we ran
our own warehouse for a while so that
was like you know ultimately my problem
if it if things went wrong and I spent
many weekends you know like breaking
down uh pallets and reorganizing the
warehouse and making it work and looking
at the numbers and being like why is
this person's well you know maybe we
should measure their rates and like this
guy's picking 80 products per hour and
this one's making 40. is it a person
thing or is this guy just lazy or what's
going on like and then just dealing with
all those issues you know one guy
threatened to kill another guy today at
work all right
um there's nothing in the handbook for
that
you know this doesn't make me money but
I think it can lose me did you really
have that incident you had that incident
you got a call that was uh hey um this
one guy just threatened to kill the
other guy like what should I do like it
was a kind of a serious threat
he's mad like I don't think he's gonna
do it but he did yell it in front of
everybody
I was like well I think you gotta fire
that guy
um right now and I don't know why you're
on the phone with me and then the other
person like why are they why is that guy
want to kill him what did he do instead
like you know can we just replace all
these people with somebody else you know
it was a it was not a if there's it's a
very hard thing right it's hard like
getting Warehouse Crews that are happy
productive and kind you know and and
reliable is not like a thing for anybody
I have a friend who runs the Ecommerce
store and they go I'm shutting down my
warehouse tomorrow like where can I move
or like oh what happened what happened
he goes
um someone just [__] all over the floor
in the warehouse for no reason
what did he do she goes he goes she what
is she why did she do it I was like wow
just
for a woman to just [__] on the floor in
a warehouse he's like
what what happened what did it take was
it a spite [__] or was it an accident
[__] I mean the intent matters I asked
all the wrong questions apparently
because I didn't I didn't ask that one I
had 10 questions but that wasn't one
what about the NBA player all right NBA
player so we meet an NBA player in L.A
this isn't my story I wasn't there for
this but Ben uh related to me is very
funny he's like um he talked about like
yeah so is it uh it's kind of like what
do you say to these guys right so like
they get a bunch of fanboys
and you don't want to be a fanboy in
general I would say there's really two
learnings the first was
um we go to this thing there's a bunch
of NBA players
but who cares uh like you know they're
cool I I think they're cool I think
they're it's cool what they do but like
this event you know it's like ah it's
hard to like
what are you gonna do they're not gonna
be your friend like this is like very
unlike what do you think is gonna happen
here like you go in excited it's like oh
this person's gonna be here you know
what they're thinking you know what
they're thinking which is like damn Sean
you're pretty tall you ever lace up like
you know we we
we need we need a fist like are you
interested like that's what you want to
happen right yeah exactly it's like
we've been waiting for this you know
this Indian guy with no athleticism like
you know would you like to become my
best friend and come on the road with us
like you know what what's gonna happen
like meeting Drake and to be like hey
you're really like you're really good at
speaking do you happen to have a mixtape
on you that I can check out you want to
just hit the studio real quick yeah
that's how you want to happen so
I think the realization was we got
excited to go to this event but it's
also like cool this event is cool but
that's not gonna happen nothing's gonna
happen that's awesome from this event in
that way
um two things happen we meet a team
owner again Ben runs facial recognition
software he's like that guy's a minority
owner of the Philadelphia 76ers or
something like that I was like how do
you know the minority owners of this
he's like I recognize him from something
I read and I was like and nobody's
talking to this guy because nobody knows
it's all kind of like older looking dude
so we go up to him we're like hey you're
blah blah blah normally when Ben does
this the person is so elated that
somebody kind of knows them that you're
a fan of theirs they're nobody's talking
to them otherwise they're kind of like
they know they're actually pretty dope
but nobody at this event knows they're
dope
this is the opposite this guy just
totally big dogged us and made us seem
like we were pieces of [__] so we're
like oh cool
um
I asked you 10 questions you gave me
exactly 10 words as answers so one word
per question and uh you left your
airpods in the whole time and then you
looked at us at the end like if you ask
one more question I'm gonna [__] slap
you yeah
and then we had the basketball player
experience where Ben takes a Ben's like
oh look I got this photo with this like
famous NBA player and
we had a realization the realization was
this
it's dope if these guys were our friends
but it's not gonna happen this way the
only dope situation is not that we meet
them and we're a fan of them and we they
recognize us as a fan but that they're a
fan of what we do and we're a fan of
what they do that's the only cool
version of this is do something dope so
that they have respect for you as you
have respect for them so you should
actually spend your time instead of
chasing them to meet them and get a
picture with them and whatever just do
dope [__] become a magnet where other
people who are awesome will respect you
and want to meet you and want to talk to
you or have something that they you know
some common ground that they could find
peer versus Fanboy yeah so like showing
them your calves was not gonna like cut
it like oh like I run a 5 4 40. does
that do anything for you can you jump
can you jump high those calves are
looking great
yeah uh I
I wear a Fitbit
we have so much
um so all right next thing was NBA
players like so I have nothing to lose
at this point so we're like uh
so like what's it like just like having
you know tons of chicks that want to be
with you like how do you do that how do
you navigate that he's like because
we're like yeah he's got he's like I got
a wife I got kids and he's like um
he's like I told my wife I said this
every time somebody has that voice yeah
I mean only good things come after that
tone he goes I said baby
um you're happy right yeah I'm happy
maybe you got the house of your dreams
right yeah yeah baby I gave you three
beautiful children right you sure did
they're beautiful children he goes baby
you can buy anything you want on this
credit card right yeah yeah yeah
baby you got to be called my wife right
all right
what more do you want baby
I just had an open conversation with my
wife that like look
you're gonna have a bunch of amazing
things in your life
and so am I
oh my God I hate that by the way I hate
that of course you hate that I mean it's
uh it's not necessarily something that's
admirable I'm just saying it was
something that was [__] hilarious and
nobody is that honest and I thought wow
to have the the honesty to tell a
stranger that story is a confidence
level that I could only admire
um you know do I do that with my wife no
of course not would I want to even well
I do it with my wife except it's a
little bit different it's like hey Sarah
look you know if someone comes in this
home I'm gonna go and fight to the debt
to protect you right whatever you want
I'll give you I'll do anything for you
take out the trash please usually it's
more like that it's like will you be the
one who takes out the the dishwasher
today let you do it this week and
tomorrow when someone breaks into our
home I'll die for you normally it's
normally that's the argument that I've
made yeah yeah these are all not great
traits I would say but I found it
hilarious This falls in line with just a
general thing which was people in La say
wild [__] like
really are so like name droppy and muddy
droppy it's disgusting isn't it but
they're not even really even aware of it
it's crazy like they'll be like um this
made up example but like
um
yeah yeah we can meet at my place it's
over on um you know Beverly and whatever
it's a 4.2 million dollar property it's
like whoa whoa why why did you add that
at the end like completely unnecessary
information
complete brag uh out of nowhere and I
just kept getting sideswiped by brags as
I was walking through L.A just oh up Sir
you dropped this Oh that's oh that's a
producer you know yeah that's a name
okay here you go take that dude I
couldn't believe it and I think SF is
obnoxious San Francisco is obnoxious in
its own way which was you'll be like Oh
I'm gonna eat dinner they're like dinner
is you know actually a necessary study
show it's like what dude I just want to
eat dinner like don't like make me like
we don't have to like be transhuman
right now like you know we don't have to
like
um like not everything has to be a thing
or like you know we don't have to use AI
to like you know go get a smoothie right
now but like you know San Francisco is
obnoxious in its own ways but the LA
version of being obnoxious I found to be
very strange yeah it makes me really
uncomfortable whenever I'm there it's um
every every city is a dick measuring
contest but uh the type that they
measure in
launchable is right in San Francisco
yeah how ambitious are you right no you
say the craziest thing you're working on
no no you say the crazy investment you
just made it's like it's an ambition
contest and New York is like some power
contest and La is basically like a Fame
uh a Fame contest or a network contest
like who do you know and who knows you
when I uh when my wife used to work at
Facebook one time Facebook rented out
the baseball stadium 18 T Park and I
remember going there and we wore nice
clothes like a suit jacket or whatever
but then the engineers would wear it was
like a contest to see who could look the
most schleppy so it would be like one
guy wearing a tuxedo t-shirt it's like
oh I see it's like you're ironic that's
funny and then another guy would be like
just only wearing pajamas and
Birkenstocks right or another guy like
only pajamas to put like dress shoes
it's like oh it's cute you make a joke
like how you think that that means
you're dressing up get it I get it
you're like a brilliant guy you're
Einstein and that's the type of contest
that you would see there whereas in La
it's like uh Land Rovers Range Rovers
and uh fancy cars and um everyone has
beautiful white teeth and like have you
noticed that there the teeth in L.A
veneers
yeah what about the souvenirs were I
don't know just it was a blind spot for
me I didn't even know what the hell
veneers were didn't know who do you know
how you get them dude I went down the
rabbit hole I went on YouTube for like
three hours what are these things you
like drill each tooth so it's almost
looks like a spike and then you like put
up these fake things on there and glue
them on there so your teeth are like
ruined I believe like they're they're
changed forever they are they shave them
down I think the bad version is when
they really shaved too much and it
becomes like a little spiced and you
look like you have little baby teeth I
think the good version is they just take
a layer of the enamel off and then they
basically glue a fake tooth front onto
your thing and it looks off like a
decade and then you like get them
switched
and you have these pearly ones they look
awful they look like Barney teeth
remember Barney that like puppet or the
like it was just like one strip of white
yeah I think the good version because I
was like again I went down the rabbit
hole like the good doc makes them look
like they're your teeth and not just
like the generic thing uh but I said it
really like like in L.A I was like kind
of enamored by this veneers thing and I
go okay I figured it out there's only
two types of people in the world people
who have veneers and people who need
veneers because once you see people who
don't have veneers
almost everyone's teeth are pretty
pretty nasty like most people's teeth
are kind of yellow kind of you know
misshapen whatever
people generally don't have great teeth
and the people who do have veneers so
there's only two types of people in life
this is now my belief people who have
veneers or people who need them I'm
currently in the people who need them
category and maybe who knows I'll go do
them but but for some reason tell me
this
um plastic surgery like I don't think
you or I would ever be like you know
what just I wish my eyebrow was a little
higher up or whatever you know like dude
I wish my I'm not my nose was a little
different
um the cool thing about being a man is
like older men can be like pretty
smoking to women you know like George
Clooney is like a fine wine you know
what I mean like people still like them
Brad Pitt still looks smoking my wife's
been trying to convince me that like
botox for women is okay because she'll
talk about like botox I'm like no after
that just age you look beautiful like
it's cool that we're gonna age together
then I met a couple people who get BOTOX
and they're like it's not that big a
deal so maybe my opinion is changing on
Botox but in general I would say plastic
surgery I'm like Let It Be let's age
together and we're gonna look awesome so
I'm generally pretty against that me too
uh totally was in that camp as I met
more people
[Music]
I'm like
it's way more prevalent than I realized
because I'm in a dude Tech bubble uh so
and secondly
there's some things like I kind of get
the teeth thing it's like it's like
there's there's grades to it right it's
like well you do
get a haircut you do you know maybe I'll
shave your beard all right I might buy
nicer clothes okay that's that's the
thing like uh you know what if you just
like you know get to get like a a facial
treatment maybe that makes your skin
looks a little better okay it's like a
kind of like almost like a slippery
slope of the beauty thing and like yeah
but what did you see there like fake
asses and fake boobs or stuff on men
everything dude everything saw
everything
men with botox yeah fake everything
everybody's nose was everybody had the
same nose
um so that was insane uh the power of
veneers I was like yes I just love
it's a pro it's a pleasure to make you
laugh because I like seeing that smile
no don't fall down this trap do not do
it man do not yes I might show up to one
of these podcasts with the veneers and a
nose job who knows we'll see what about
the thing and or like I don't know if I
told you this I have a like a deviated
septum I went to ENT person I was like
yeah I don't know I've never been able
to breathe through my nose very well and
they're like yeah because you have like
a super screwed up thing like it's like
horrible and he's like you should get
that fixed I was like okay cool I was
like does that change how much then
they're like what looks well yeah
they're like while we're there it
doesn't have to change how it looks but
like we're doing the surgery anyways
it's very easy to like you know just
shape it and I was like
but does that make me lame and he's like
that's a personal question like it's
like I was like what do you think it's
like if I did that would I have to tell
my boys I got a nose job like what do
you like telling to tell you like talk
to her am I gay I need a 360 opinion
here on this like you can't just hit me
with the medical I need the medical the
personal the social like I need all the
opinions he's gonna diagnose you as
being a dude
like you know uh all right maybe last
one but what about the uh Rich who did
you meet with someone who donated
hundreds of millions of dollars to a
high school
yeah so uh rich people do really stupid
things is the name of my my of this
topic which is actually they do
misguided things to help their kids so I
met multiple people who had donated
somewhere between single digit Millions
to double-digit Millions one person said
100 million plus well I I don't believe
it because we're I don't even know where
that would go to a high school I'll give
you one I'll give you one Fame where
would even 10 million go to a public
example which is that uh you know the
Fertitta Brothers the guys who own the
UFC before they sold it the guys who
owned casinos in Vegas
they uh their kids like to play football
as many kids do but unlike many football
parents
these guys decided that their the high
school their alma mater needed a uh like
a division one college level football
facility and donated tens of millions of
dollars they haven't said the exact
number but you can kind of triangulate
it because they later donated like 10 or
15 million bucks to a college and it's
less than what they gave their high
school for their football oh my God and
it's like basically they gave at least
20 million dollars to a high school to
build a better football facility so
their kids would have a better shot
at becoming a better football player and
I was like this is such a misguided way
such a like inefficient way to help your
kids
um and I've met many people like this I
know people who are wealthy beyond
measure and I asked them why are you
still working like so many hours what
are you doing why are you taking all
this risk they're like okay they're like
my dad when I wanted to be an
entrepreneur
um
said you're never gonna do it and he
refused to give me any money to start
start so I struggled so hard at the
beginning
um when my kids turn 18 I'm going to
give them each 20 million dollars and
say like you know I will support you in
building any business you want with that
you know someone who said this is their
literal plan uh they like and they're
saying it bragging to me again crazy
brag how old are their kids I mean their
kids are currently their oldest maybe 10
years old
um and their youngest is four so
I have four kids that's 80 million
dollar uh uh you know
allowance that they're creating trying
to trust fund that they're kidding
creative with the kids to start these
businesses and I told him I was like
well you know that like because you
didn't have the resources you developed
all these skills which is what made you
successful in business like you weren't
if you were handed 20 million dollars I
don't think you would actually be who
you are today
um
so I love that you're trying to help
your kids but I just don't think what
you're doing which is working super hard
when they're kids being so busy being
busy that you're kind of away from them
making all this money that you plan to
hand them at 18. like this sounds like a
recipe for disaster but you know people
it's a horrible
I don't think that message was was
received very well
um but you know I just found that people
do crazy things in the name of of like
their kids and money no I think that
that's crazy I think that's exactly how
you create like a little bit of future
heroin I'll tell you a couple other ones
I think are good talk to an investor
friend so I have a friend who was a VC
at one of the big VC firms he's left he
left and started doing his own thing but
he has a style and a strategy I think is
very different than most people I find
it very fascinating so if I asked you I
said what's what is like draw me like a
picture of the typical Silicon Valley VC
like can you just describe some things
about them like you know what what are
they like what are they doing you know
like just the average VC let's say
average VC a a tall looking white guy
who wears um a sweater
um and brown shoes or shoes that have
white soles like white bottoms uh and
they basically meet tons and tons of
people of tons of coffee meetings yeah
tons of coffee meetings lots of
introductions from other people who come
from really amazing universities and
they'll pass on most of them but then
they'll invest uh like 50 to 100
companies uh smallish checks and then
never hear from uh they don't really
talk to the founder often unless things
are going really bad and they [__] out
yeah exactly they say they're going to
be value-add they invest in uh dozens uh
maybe 40 50 companies over their
lifespan of like a couple years they're
taking tons of coffee meetings they're
super agreeable the only kind of smile
and say nice things to your face
typically they cast a wide net they love
going to meet Mark networking events
they'll say that like uh we're a
Founders first company founder first
we're founder-friendly we invest in
world changing ideas yeah all of them
all of them only invest in the best
somehow
um every single VC only invests in the
best uh they
they do all those things
this is an investor friend that has a
Twitter egg profile picture
they go to no networking events that are
like VC run and and or like kind of
generic founder events
um they do go to random events that are
like
oh I'm going to this biohacker Meetup in
Downtown Oakland where people are going
to like shoot themselves up with DNA
it's like okay I'll go to that like they
go to those types of events
um they have a strategy which is
basically here's what he told me he goes
every year one company becomes like kind
of the center of the universe
and my job is to have invested in that
company three years ago
and I go wow okay I like that so what do
you give me examples he goes well like
you know uh back when we met I met this
person in 2012 or 2013 they were like
you know stripe was actually the center
of the universe at that time stripe was
the company
that like was the clear breakout
recently he's like um most recent ones
last year would have been open AI so uh
open AI before kind of like our like
kind of early chat gbt or before
releasing gpt3
um
right now I go right now who is it right
now he goes ozempic Olympic is the
center of the US right now and I was
like oh interesting so not just like
tech companies when I last time I talked
to this person was maybe three years ago
um in earnest and I was like so what are
you up to nowadays and generic usually
the answer is like oh a little bit of
this a little bit of that this person
said I quit my job and I am just hunting
down a way to own a piece of only fans
I go what
porn thing and he's like yeah
only fans I think is going to be massive
I think it's you know it's one of these
it's the center of the universe right
now and people are going to be the
center of the universe people don't
realize it I think it's going to be one
I think it's going to be the one of this
like this year kind of cohort this is
going to be the company that matters so
my only mission is to add so much value
to the owner of only fans that um
I can invest in it or own a piece of it
somehow
and if I don't whatever at least I was
helping that rocket ship go and you know
previously it might have been SpaceX or
Tesla was like you know those that comp
the company and
um
Bitcoin ethereum like those are like
some of the other ones that had their
their they owned that that year there
was no more valuable company that was
like creating more value that would then
in the future be realized and uh
I just thought it was awesome I thought
it was an amazing
I was I'm just so happy that this
person's a friend that like thinks so
differently operates so differently than
the the average person that has he been
successful has been successful and he
told me I was like I go so what's the
strategy here he goes oh I'm trying to
make all the best investments I can so I
can make the worst investment of my life
and buy this like soccer club in Europe
that I grew up loving and he's like I
said I'm trying to make the best
investments ever so that I can make the
one worst investment ever and uh and
does he use other people's money in the
past he did I think now he's doing a lot
of his own or he'll raise spvs like I
was like oh you invest in this company
cool what what how much do you invest he
goes 100 million dollars
he's like yeah I raised a 100 million
dollar SPV because I believe in this
company and I'm and you just it puts
your own conviction and ambition and
check you're like so what's the company
I believe most in how much have I plowed
into that and why is that number not 100
million right like you can only like
self-check when you hear stuff like this
in a good way it's a frame breaker I
said where'd you get the 100 million he
goes from one LP
I convinced one person and that they
were actually already convinced actually
that person was kind of already
convinced that this was a good company I
busted my ass to get the ability to put
100 million dollar check in and they put
the money in what did he put 100 million
dollars in can you say I can't say has
it worked uh again it's you bake these
things three four years ahead and we'll
find out like did that company was that
the right place to concentrate like a
laser beam of conviction so I loved that
conversation and meeting that person so
that was one uh that I think is great
um
let me give you one more that I think is
oh here's a quick one neighborhoods not
cities you're I think a great person to
talk about this because you've been
traveling around trying to find cool
places to live
you don't pick at the city level you
pick at the neighborhood level
um it's actually what is the best
neighborhood to be in not what is the
best city to live in I just that was
just an obvious understanding to me once
you go to a place like LA or you know
you've done this in in New York or uh
Brooklyn or and it's really hard to do
that by the way like the idea that like
let's say that you're a normal person
your home is likely going to be the
biggest purchase of your entire life and
it will unfortunately be the uh for most
people it'll be the largest portion of
their net worth and it's pretty insane
that you make that decision a 20 or
30-year decision off one maybe two one
hour visits right uh like in like for a
uh uh open house it's it's it's insane
and you did this I think way back in the
day I think you created one of these for
San Francisco I think it was the um
the roommate infographic for
neighborhoods in San Francisco it's like
if you live in this neighborhood here's
who your roommate's gonna be like which
is so brilliant because it's a about
neighborhoods and B
it's about people
um because people is also what makes
your experience when you're in a in a
city it's not it's not the environment
yeah
basically in 2014 we had this app and in
order to make it popular we launched in
five cities San Francisco Boston
Manhattan
LA and Chicago I believe and what we did
was we're like all right in order to
make things go viral we have to name as
many names of local restaurants and
local people that we can think of
because those people will share it if we
name like 50 of them in each one that's
50 people sharing in that City That's
How we'll get uh that's how we'll get
popular and so we created this thing
called the stereotypical roommates of
Los Angeles stereotypical roommates of
San Francisco and if you Google them you
can find them and we just made like a
infographic that made fun of each
neighborhood and all the brands and
places that they shopped at and that way
you could like figure out what
restaurants were like that neighborhood
but those restaurants and the people in
those neighborhoods would share and
here's the thing at that period I don't
think I'd never been to New York I had
never been to Boston we just looked at
Yelp we just looked at Yelp and look at
what are the most popular things and we
found the jokes that people were making
about it and then that's how we made the
infographic and it went like crazy I
think we got tens and many many tens of
thousands of downloads for the app in
the first day I saw that before I ever
met you I read that thing when I moved
to San Francisco somebody shared it
because it was so funny and like kind of
like oh that's funny because it's true
yeah like so it was actually useful too
because it was like it was a little bit
stereotyping generalizing but it was it
was true for the most part so I thought
that was so so good and I kind of wish
somebody did that for every city now
like exactly whenever I go and look at
new neighborhoods I I try always go to a
bar and I say what's the stereotype of
this neighborhood and I'll ask the
bartender or whatever I'm like tell me
the stereotypes uh and they'll be like
oh a lot of gay people are moving in and
I'm like all right up and coming got it
that's what that means like gentrifying
or like oh like what's the stereotype of
this neighborhood tons of strollers so
I'm like all right Rich uh young
families all right got it what else you
know what I mean like there's all these
like things yeah there's like codes it's
like that's a it's like you know if
you're in the government's like oh it's
a it's a three eight three three that's
the government code that means x uh this
is the same thing it's like when
somebody says critically acclaimed cool
code for not profitable thank you uh
moving yeah or boring
for the everyday man got it okay yeah I
got a couple other quick ones for you
rattle off uh one more I'll give you a
networking hack so Tim first back in the
day did this blog post called how to
build a world-class Network and record
time or something like that I love that
I I remember reading that and like kind
of like getting inspired by that
um so I don't know if you know this but
business partner Ben I think is the
greatest networker in the world actually
I've now come to realize this I had no
idea
um
I had no idea what was going on until
recently I've now now learned this um
he is working the phones and he is just
like it's so funny too what he does is
he just checks in on people like just
this morning he texted my friend from
college that I had introduced him to
once it's my one of my best friends from
college that were helping buy a business
and he goes yo I uh yo I remember you
said that the close date was supposed to
be 7 31 did it end up closing I was like
bro how did you oh my god remember to
check in
like he's the he's the perfect boyfriend
basically he's just [__] checking in
and supporting everybody like bar shop
you could probably attest to this and
our and all of our we work together
I probably text you
I don't know a couple times a year Max
uh and it's usually about something
that's like urgent sort of transactional
can I'm just guessing that you talked to
Ben fairly often uh could you just
describe this for a second because I
think there's something to learn here
out of this whole thing yeah I could
pull up my text he he probably hits me
up like two or three times a week like
how's The X Project going or how's that
how's X going yeah he's a beast
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
so I noticed this because I would meet
people
and then somehow afterwards they're only
keeping in touch with Ben I'm like dude
am I just unlikable I was like and I
think there's something to it I
definitely give off some some stink
that's like you know repels people but
Ben has the opposite effect on people he
draws them in he's like a Golden
Retriever and he's always smiling he's
just harmless and people people like him
and he's helpful he's just supportive
and helpful to everybody and so he's
like he knows here's what he's figured
out he's figured out
that most people just nobody checks in
with them so he checks in on how's that
that your mission in life how's that
going does he do it on his cell phone or
on the computer on his phone then they
reply with like a long ass update and
I'm like you're basically just saying
Sup and then the sup is generating this
like highly interesting response and
then what he does is he's just like
connects dots so he'll be like oh you're
stuck to that guy like oh you uh you you
really like this TV show we just met the
writer you should meet him and he'll
disconnect dots and like he's just a DOT
connector and then people are like oh
that was helpful or like once he knows
you're trying to do X like let's say he
knows Sam you're trying to um
do some uh body fat thing he'll then
just start sending you tweets just
little links like he doesn't related to
it and he's also
what's it called like infatigable like
you can ignore like you probably ignored
the last four that he sent don't matter
no hard feelings gonna keep them coming
and I'm like wow this is just a recipe
so this kind of led me to this
understanding of okay Ben is world class
at this fantastic but in general Ben's
kind of like my wing man he's like my
number two and everybody's got like a
number two at some it's once you get to
a certain level you get like a number
two and actually the number two guy
network is the most undertapped resource
so why were we meeting these NBA players
because we're friends with the number
two of an NBA player and it's like and
guess what nobody knows that guy
everybody wants to get to the NBA player
nobody even knows this guy's name
but he's got all the access he's got 98
of the access to the NBA guy has but
he's got two percent of the like
um the the busyness and which we did
with uh with huberman's guy
um God I'm blanking on his first name uh
what's his name um Rob Rob Moore uh yeah
I went out to I hung out with that guy
in LA and he was like he runs the Huber
bed show he remembers the face but this
guy's got all the keys he's like oh yeah
we interviewed this person if you ever
want to talk let me know the keys to the
kingdom and generally these people are
nicer less busy
um they're the ones who actually do a
lot of the [__] work so they're
actually more interesting people
um uh they also were kind of like the
gatekeeper like they decide who could
say and who gets out what opportunities
come in what gets out and they're hit up
way less they're hit up way less so
they're way more available and they're
very helpful like they they know a bunch
of other people and so I'm like oh [__]
the number two guy Network
I don't know what I'm gonna do with this
but I've had the Insight now and I'm
like I I actually get along better with
the number two guys but for all those
reasons I just mentioned and
I just think that this is like an
undertap resource and I get why
everybody hits up Ben now
because he's the number two guy and some
people have figured out this Arbitrage
that you should hit up the number two
guy because he's you know nicer smarter
better faster more accessible all the
things and um so this was just a
realization for me on the networking
side one of the one of the few like
big unlocks I think that I've had before
we wrap up did you what was this thing
about bucked up is that someone you met
with in La I didn't meet them but I
heard I met somebody who told me their
story and I was blown away had you ever
heard of bucked up no what is it so Buck
does it using a hunting thing is this a
hunting thing no no okay let me tell you
don't even look it up let me just tell
you the story so
um starts basically in the uh in the in
early 2000s there's these two guys two
twin brothers I think and they just do
affiliate marketing so they're like
affiliate marketing they're like hey
um it's 2001. Google is not that
competitive we can basically say oh you
want leads for your lawyer practice cool
what are you gonna pay us we'll get you
leads for that you want leads for your
apartment thing we'll get you that you
want leads for this uh this supplement
will get you that so and at that time
those guys killed it those guys are
killing it kill it uh by Twenty so
they've been doing they do this for
about 10 years they're making money by
2010 they're generating 25 million a
year in Revenue with only three
employees
that means they're basically pulling in
like 20 million a year of profit uh yeah
if they're if they're if they're uh cpcs
are low or the cost per clicks are low
which bet back then they were maybe I'm
super aggressive yeah I thought it was
it'd be pretty low there maybe I'm super
aggressive let's say it's
eight to ten million in profit I think
it's a very yeah a a ton which is just
amazing three people doing this so this
was like you know what they were doing
my partner my partner Joe by the way Joe
spies are my partner in Hampton he
started this and when he was 25 he sold
the business it was called epic
advertising he was the affiliate
marketer he sold a portion of the
business for 250 million dollars that's
amazing I mean it was all this affiliate
marketing stuff and so these guys
they're doing the affiliate marketing
thing and a guy comes to them and says
um this is now like a decade later right
and it comes to him and says hey I have
this supplement called L-Arginine uh and
the Brand's called L-Arginine Plus
and he's like I don't know what
L-Arginine does but like um it's like a
vitamin I think it helps make you sleep
or does it give you energy I think it uh
gives you energy or does it help your
brain function better who the hell knows
I don't know it's one of those I think
you're supposed to drink it with
caffeine and it gives you energy I think
yeah maybe uh like right now it's just
some generic [__] stuff it's the one
but back then it was Arginine was the
one and so yeah whatever the guy goes
acai bowls and [__] it's all it's all or
a Kai barrier whatever the [__] that
thing is it's all a different thing
every time what's that [__] called
what's that Brazilian [__] called
Akai I ain't no acai berries it's like
whenever I see the word uh it's all
right what's that quinoba quinoa uh
quinoa yeah it's like what do you call
uh do you ever used to call uh I used to
think that like La Quinta Inn was
Laquita you know what I'm talking about
the queen ahead
I don't know the thing you said you say
it how do you say it now because I think
it's also completely wrong what's it
called La Quinta
what's supposed to be called I think
it's King time but I don't know uh
Laquita so so a guy approaches him says
hey I'm making 250 a day on this
L-Arginine thing will you guys be my
affiliate marketers quickly in three
weeks they ramp it up it's now making
like over three thousand dollars a day
okay that's pretty good three thousand
dollars a day that's like 100k a month
they own 50 of this thing
and they buy l-arginine.com to get an
exact match they're ranking number one
that's doing pretty well and then he
reads this article so he's interested in
this supplement game he reads this
article that Major League Baseball just
banned deer antler spray
never heard of it what the hell's dear
antler spray looks it up finds that deer
antler uh has some extract that's
supposed to help you with recovery damn
must be if it's so good that the MLB
bans it that means that [__] must be
fire like there's gonna be a lot of so
he he takes he he has the right what is
that Chris Farley thing did you learn
the right lesson he learned the right
lesson from that news which was this
[__] must be fire and every athlete's
gonna want it so he buys deer
antlerspray.com for eight dollars and
he's uh he owns the domain
he's the number one rank and it goes
okay at first not not a huge demand but
he's kind of he's there
and then I don't know if you remember
this but one year before the Super Bowl
Ray Lewis was the kill the guy uh no he
killed the guy I think the year before
but during this playoff run he gets hurt
got it and there's a two-week yeah
there's like a there's like an extra
weak rest between like the Super Bowl
and the playoffs or whatever I think The
Story Goes Ray Lewis is hurt but he's
gonna play in the Super Bowl and then he
plays amazing and they win the Super
Bowl and he's and it comes out that he
used deer antler spray to like recover
during that week and to like get rid of
the pain and allow him to play well
demand explodes through the roof baby
and uh GNC comes to him and says hey
we'd like um 30 units he's like okay
cool no problem oh no sorry 30 000 units
and he's like oh what they're sold out
everywhere as soon as they they they
they they they get all this influx of
demand
they're they're trying to keep up so for
one or two years they're just keeping up
with the new demand and being the number
one player in this deer antler spray
thing
but as they go they're like okay we're
kind of limited it's like very Niche
what if we expand this to um to
something a little bit bigger so they
changed the name from deer antler spray
to bucked up they kind of stay with a
deer oh my God they changed to bucked up
because one of the GNC franchisees who
they were chilling with goes yeah you
know what sells really well but like you
know look it doesn't look that good is
these pre-workout supplements so
basically the powder you take before you
work out remember no explode yeah no
explode uh dude that's the biggest acid
that would that would you could remove
paint with that thing I used to take
that [__] and you would lift so much
weight but it would make you feel
miserable after I don't even know what
was in it yeah your fella your heart was
gonna explode it should have just been
called like you know artery explode and
like you know one out of ten people die
of this thing it was crazy but like that
category of pre-workout supplements
turns out is a very big category
um so bucked up today
they say is the number one pre-workout
supplement
this thing does guess how much revenue
this does I have no idea 10. 250 million
a year apparently bucked up does dude
the flavors so it's called motherbucker
that's one of their things the
motherbucker and it just says like their
slogan should be like strong as an ox
like this is like ridiculous
Focus strength energy the mother of all
pre-workouts motherbucker that's crazy
to me this is nuts you know sometimes
when I'm flipping the channels on TV
I'll see like um you know Hassan minhaj
and he's just like you know this guy
who's his comedian he makes the world
laugh he's so good looking he's you know
happy he's having all this success and I
think
you know I was maybe one or two you know
like turns away from from going down
that path when you see bucked up do you
think this because I feel like you were
one or two right turns away from being
the Creator owner and sole proprietor of
buckedup.com selling motherbucker
pre-workout powders to people on the
internet
yeah maybe maybe I mean I don't know a
thousand square foot factory in Missouri
uh and just like you know I had a soul
patch a huge antler tattoo on your back
yeah
dude listen the flavors are woke AF
another one is the vamp Heist the the
other one is the Banff High stimulation
uh another one is the lfg Pre-Workout
let's [__] go another one is called
rut this is hilarious these are all like
really good names of like really mean
dogs you know what I mean like I'm gonna
have like a really like my junkyard dog
named Buck get him buck that's like what
this stuff is you know or like run yeah
like
this is crazy this is a deer antler are
you sure this is from that to this it's
kind of an insane uh insane story and uh
yeah and they still kill it yeah they're
doing really well right now apparently I
mean I mean I'm talking to one I I know
this from one guy and then what you
Google about them but like apparently
just crushing it
oh my God I have no idea what's in this
stuff I would like I mean this might be
a legit performance enhancing drug is it
still illegal for the MLB because maybe
I will order it
exactly like haha that's so insane you
know as you check out
well people talk about performance
enhancing drugs like it's a bad thing
but I'm like I would love my performance
to be enhanced right do you know what I
mean like the main problem with my
performance that it's unenhanced right
now yeah how do I enhance my performance
I really want it to be enhanced I prefer
it to be enhanced than unenhanced so
like give me the PED so I'm like in
favor of some Peds uh not not if it
means you break the rule but uh
we haven't talked about this did you see
that thing the enhanced games that
somebody was creating
uh was that the um was that just the uh
different sports but for steroid users
it's basically like
it's like you know I feel like every
College bro had this like
conversation in their dorm room which
like they should just do the Olympics
but with the drugs like you could take
anything and see what happens like I
want to see somebody run like a two
second 100 meter dash and it's like
these guys created it it's called The
enhanced games and it's happening and I
don't know if you've uh it came out and
it almost looked like
um like satire like it wasn't happening
so if you go to its enhanced.com it's a
better version of the Olympics yeah yeah
exactly that's a great that's a great
we're basically Airbnb but better
[Laughter]
um I can't find their their website
websites down right now the website's
down but enhanced games is a plan
international sports event where the
athletes will not be subjected to drug
testing it's meant to take place in
December of 2024. so the guy Aaron
D'Souza is the same guy that Peter Thiel
funded to take down Gawker by the way
okay so sign me up
you know uh best LinkedIn ever so he
here's how he does it he says athletes
are adults they have the right to do
with their body as they wish my body my
choice your body your choice and no
government uh should be making these
decisions for athletes particularly
those around the FDA
so here's what he said he goes here's
the game plan he goes uh every athlete
who participates is going to be a part
owner in the thing because you're you're
generating you know part of the
opportunity I assume that if you were an
Olympian you won a gold medal your life
is made it's not the case it's sad to
see the people who've achieved the
highest level of Human Excellence are
living living an objectively
impoverished existence afterwards
um
but you know the bureaucrats who own
these things make millions
um we took the Olympics has 13 000
athletes we're reducing that to maybe a
thousand
um with no special infrastructure so
instead of costing 100 billion to
deliver this it'll cost us you know just
double digit Millions
and um
yeah they have like a bunch of things uh
you know here's kind of like their their
belief system so it says
the enhanced games will be a competitor
to the corrupt and dysfunctional Olympic
Games the first International it'll be
the first international sports event
without drug testing Olympics are about
to pass it's about Greek gods from
history the enhanced games are about the
future we're building superheroes and
um
it talks about how the ioc is corrupt
like the the committee that runs the
Olympics and
um that you know anti-aging gets stymied
because of all the anti-science like you
know authorities trying to like take
drugs out of out of uh performance and
we're trying to do the Opposites my body
my choice
um
he says uh thinking think back 50 years
ago being a gay man was like being an
enhanced man today it stigmatized
marginalized and illegal in some senses
yeah I don't know about that
um yeah and then I don't know if it's
actually gonna happen or not it seems it
seemable their website doesn't work so
like we'll see they can't afford their
GoDaddy renewal for the domain but uh no
I think I'm I'm I think I'm cool with
that my a big I mean besides Lance
Armstrong kind of used to be my hero and
then he like got in trouble for lying
and I kind of like got upset about that
but besides that whole lying thing I was
like they're all doing it and he's doing
it as well and he still won so like it's
kind of fair right uh so I and so I do
get that I I I'm kind of on board with
that and I think a lot of the Peds are
pretty amazing like you know what uh EPO
is it makes you uh get more red blood
cells in your in your blood endurance
basically yeah yeah better endurance and
I hear about that stuff and I'm like
that sounds great give me more of that I
want that uh you know what I mean like
then there's some uh Ana box steroids
that you know you'll die young there was
this um
which I don't like but there was this
one have you seen the guy on Instagram
he was only 30 but I think his name was
Joe I forget what his like handle was it
was like Joe like all ripped or
something and he was the guy who you
would see flexing and he was so lean and
big that you would see it looked like he
had little spiders in his chest because
all the little muscles were like flexing
I think his name was like Joe Flex have
you seen that guy no well he died like
last week he died like oh that was that
guy okay yeah yeah I've seen he died
last week because uh he definitely was
on the juice uh and he was just it's
really hard to be that lean for that
long so you have to be on a ton of stuff
and he died and so like I'm not in favor
of that type of stuff but uh some of the
other performance enhancing drugs like I
actually think that you could you you'd
be a healthier longer living human being
if you took some of that stuff
or like blood doping so like in the 60s
this runner in Finland named blase Baron
he would like go up in the mountains and
no one would see him when he was
training and what they allege that he
did with blood doping you could just
take out some of your blood and you
could put it in a refrigerator and that
gives that oxidizes it gives it it or uh
it gives you more red blood cells
ultimately and you just inject it back
in your body that's considered illegal
that's crazy to me it's not illegal it's
against it's against rules uh for for
the Olympics but that's insane that
blood doping like that is illegal it's
like well dude it's just your blood
you're just freezing it and putting it
back in you things like that you can't
do but I've thought about that uh I
think it'd be amazing there was a guy in
Netflix who did it where he was an
amateur cyclist and he was like I'm
gonna blood dope and I'm gonna document
this and this was uh the whole
documentary and it was awesome he
crushed it he killed it he like improved
so much and I thought that's pretty cool
I think this actually would be a good uh
YouTube or podcast
um Channel have you ever gone on YouTube
down a rabbit hold of
college ethics classes have you ever
seen this no no sounds boring as hell
but it's actually kind of interesting
it's not very interesting because it's
not made for YouTube but basically if
you go like you could basically sit in
on a Stanford or Harvard ethics class
well they'll pose some question like
should you be allowed to like or
performance enhancing drugs should they
be allowed in the Olympics or whatever
like some philosophical question like
the version of the trolley thing where
it's like if you could save five lives
and pull the trolley and kill one would
you do it right like that those kind of
like moral and ethical like thought
experiment questions and you see people
just stand up in a college lecture hall
and they're like uh I say no because
blah blah blah and then somebody says
um I disagree I would say yes because I
think that what about blah blah blah and
you just see the debate I think debate
is actually like pretty
um interesting I think if somebody did
that well you could do a kind of like
NPR style or gimlet style like
intelligent but entertaining podcast
series or YouTube channel that like just
gets like find these things like the
equivalent of like um uh somebody I was
at one of these dinners in La somebody
goes I had jury duty and the case that I
had jury duty for was actually kind of
interesting this guy
um
this guy goes online and he's in this
online Forum or Community for like kind
of like kinky meetups okay nothing
illegal about that and
um
there's a woman there who says
um hey me and my husband really want to
do a thing it's you know
here's our thing it's kind of weird but
like we want somebody to come over and
we want to role play like a kind of like
a rape scenario and uh she's like so you
know I'm looking for somebody who wants
to do that this guy's like that's fun I
can do that and she's like cool
um
so here's what's gonna happen you're
gonna come over to this place I'm gonna
act surprised I'm gonna say no that's
part of the bit we're gonna do it
anyways and you know we're all good
was it like a setup was it like a
different woman
no the guy
there's bad so the husband was on this
forum as acting as if he was the woman
saying that that's what I mean in on it
she wasn't his wife oh no so oh no now
this guy's so the jury duty was should
this guy be go to jail for rape what a
horrible scenario for everyone involved
lose lose right like just um
but it was kind of like an interesting
question it's like well like on one hand
what a conniving husband yeah it's like
okay definitely the husband should be in
trouble like that's kind of a scenario
but this guy like should he go to jail
for like 20 years because of the
scenario or not like and the the vote
was basically like should this go to
like it's like an indictment so it's
like should he go to should this go to
trial or no should this not be not go to
trial or whatever
and we had this just like fascinating
dinner conversation about it with just
hearing everybody's kind of hearing like
a little bit of a healthy kind of debate
or just like a perspective on it
similarly there was another one that was
like
uh you know uh this couple
um uh looks like they're holding um
drugs like crack or whatever cop starts
chasing after him they throw something
away in the trash
um cop yeah cop grabs them they don't
have it on him he's like I saw you dump
it in the trash he opens up trash sees
it there
but who's to say they didn't throw
something else away
right should they go to jail for this
like uh this offense and it's like well
on what if you're the jury like you kind
of do think like they they probably did
it but you don't have like
um uncontroversial or whatever like
evidence that like leaves no Shadow of
Doubt that they that they did it and
it's like kind of a non-violent offense
do we really want to punish them you
start bringing your own subjective
opinion into this versus what you're
supposed to do as a jury member so
anyways I just the conversation was so
interesting that I thought I think this
could make for an interesting pod or a
YouTube channel what do you think you
have a good sense for Content what do
you think I think I think it would be
great I think I would I think you could
do a YouTube channel a 10 minute 10
minute videos where you could uh dissect
some of these interesting things and
just have one take it take a side of
debate and then people live vote
um I I think wasn't there an app that
was trying to do this where it was like
live debates and you vote on who's the
winner maybe do not remember that yeah
in 2014 yeah I think you could kill it
it's it's where it's uh you know almost
like remember uh you know drunk rap
battles where it's like Napoleon versus
like Caesar uh yeah yeah you do this in
that situation I think like it's it's an
incredibly uh interesting topic I mean
clearly if you've gotten gotten into it
yeah I think it could work
cool um all right that's all I got for
my trip to La I hope actually I had a
bunch more but uh I think that's that's
enough also Erawan you've been to this
place
yeah I went there before and I um wanted
to buy the most expensive bottle of
water they had to see what it was about
and it was like 20 or 30 bucks
but it's fun a fun fun experience how's
the water it was fine
it was normal but and I also bought like
the most expensive I wanted to I was
like whatever like the most expensive
chocolate is in water I'm getting it I
think they have like asparagus there
like asparagus water that's crazy
there's also a layup Tick Tock channel
uh you know arawan experiments or the
Erawan taste tests you just see any
famous people there though what's that
that's how you go but did you see any
famous people that's why you go
no I was just looking at the snacks is
that what I was supposed to be doing oh
God this is like
second College when I used to go to the
bar and uh you know I'm there to listen
to the music and I said I didn't meet
anybody I missed the point
you're like doing a Long Island IC
tasting
yeah you're supposed to go and see
famous people I know it's a fun
experience that place kills it uh
they're expanding I think aren't they
don't they have multiple they used to be
one just in Santa Monica I think 13 or
something like that um for those who
don't know everyone is basically like
it makes Whole Foods look like the
dollar store
yeah you're like you look down at Whole
Foods people as peasants yeah Erawan is
to Whole Foods as aioli is to mayonnaise
it's it's the like just uh Jazz up
version the cool part about it is it has
a lot of products that are like almost
like it's like a d2c pop-up shop it's
like here's a bunch of products that are
not the normal things that are on the
shelves so you can try them and they're
all three times more expensive than they
should be or maybe five times more and
um
I think a layup content thing would be
go to arawan buy all the chocolates or
buy all the chocolates versus the fancy
marijuana versus Walmart and you do
blind taste tests and you like
absolutely try to rank them and you just
give your recommendation you spend the
money on the stuff and you just do like
Air One Shopping you just you become the
air one guy like
dude if I was broke again
I'd be back I'd be back so fast because
I just know that niches are right you
just see it and you know it like another
one is pranks I hate the pranks
dude have you seen this guy who does the
I think his name is Jody or something
like that like
um
what is this guy's channel the guy who
went to sleep at an NBA at WNBA game did
you see this no
no but I hate the pranks where it's like
people like prank pick a fight with you
and then the person responds and
actually beats them up and then the
recipient is like it was just a prank
bro so this guy uh Judy on jadian on how
you say it exactly I love his video so
he goes he went to the WNBA All-Star
game he bought four courtside seats drop
like you know like whatever 25k on these
seats
and then he came with a blanket and like
it looks like an eye mask oh my God he's
like an [__] and he's like the funny
thing is they asked him about it he was
like dude I had the idea because I knew
this would like
go viral just fall asleep because he's
done it before like he goes to a
basketball game Courtside and he brought
his Barber and they put like the the bib
on him and he gets a haircut during the
game but like if you're just watching TV
like is that guy getting a haircut like
this is like very obvious and so he had
this idea I wasn't gonna do it I thought
it might be too mean I told my friend
about it I was like yo maybe you want to
do it like I was like he's like that guy
got so excited because he knew this
would go so viral I was like nah [__] it
I'm gonna do it myself he's like so I
did it he's like but then it turned into
like a political thing which is not how
I intended it like he got banned from
all NBA events yeah man from all NBA and
WNBA events for for doing this but this
guy's just so good at trolling the world
and it's like that's just like
it's a uh it's a niche that will never
get old like you get what an [__]
though it's just like infinite demand
for
um he also caught one of the NBA balls
and tried to shoot it from his seat like
because he was Courtside dude he's so
he's so he's so funny this guy
um
all right I think we should wrap up
there
that's the pod
we don't
[Music]